[Music]  Kris Jenner tears up over her daughter  Khloe Kardashian becoming a mom it gets  so emotional and addresses Kanye West's  recent controversial comments he always  does things with really good intentions  Kris gets candid on Friday's episode of  The Ellen DeGeneres Show about a lot of  things including those Tristan Thompson  cheating accusations just days before  Khloe gave birth Khloe is amazing I'm so  proud of that kid  good she's figuring it out one day at a  time and she's just the best mom already  and that baby is so cute  Ellen also asked Chris about her  son-in-law Kanye West the rapper caught  eat for his recent remarks about slavery  and president Donald Trump I know that  he will explain himself in his own way  he always does things with really good  intentions so I'm gonna let him explain  himself when the times ready  you